I'm gonna give the team.
You tell me the inconvenient
truth about this playoff team
and what can hold them back.
- Gotcha.
- The New Orleans Saints.
I'll tell you one of
the inconvenient truths there.
- What's the excuse
they've been leaning on?
- Well, I will say this.
I think one of
the inconvenient truths
and it's been exposed
a little bit
is Drew Brees and what he can
bring to the Saints offense.
I know. We're gonna
open up a can of worms here.
- What do you want? What do
you want, Who Dat Nation?
- But we talk about offenses
all the time, right?
- Yes!
- How great offenses
make you defend the whole field.
- Sure.
- But he's not— at this age,
39 years old, he's not capable
of scrambling out of the pocket,
making plays that way.
- Monday against Carolina,
when the rush got there
the play was over.
- Exactly right.
He's not gonna make
any physically demanding plays
that we're gonna go,
"Whoa, there was nobody open
the protection
wasn't that great
and he still made it happen."
And, hey, listen. He throws
the ball shorter downfield.
He's tied with Eli Manning
for 28th in football
in yards in the air.
- Intended air yards—
him and Eli tied.
- Yes, so, again, they can win the Super Bowl with him.
- Yes.
- But there is little issues
with his game
and when you see teams
take away their screens
and things like that
that offense doesn't work
as smoothly because nobody's
scared of Drew Brees
throwing bombs over their head.
- There's one team that everybody
is piling on right now—
- Yeah.
- Cuz they're excited
they no longer have a bye.
- Right.
- The Patriots.
- Ooh.
- I'm still scared
of the Patriots.
- Yes, you should be.
- Just gonna put that out there.
But what is their
inconvenient truth?
- Their inconvenient truth
is that Gronk
is no longer the greatest
mismatch in football.
That has ended.
- Wow.
- Gronk is no longer
holding the trophy
as the best tight end
in the game.
And I would even argue
that he's not
even Brady's go-to guy
all the time.
I think there's been big moments
during the year where he's gone
"I'm gonna go
to Josh Gordon here.
I trust him in this situation."
And since Josh Gordon's
been there, he's been targeted
more than any other receiver
on their team.
- I want a real truth.
- But yes, Gronk has lost a step.
I do think he's lost his
intensity, and I
don't think— hey, there's a reason
New England was rumored
to be trying to trade him
in the offseason.
I think they saw a few,
you know
dents in the armor here
that were about to come about.
- A few more dents in the armor.
- Yeah.
- L.A. Rams. This offense
has been struggling.
- Yeah.
- What's the inconvenient truth
about the Rams?
- People are gonna point
to Jared Goff, right?
- They are.
- Who's been in Strugglesville.
I mean, yes.
- One touchdown
the last three weeks.
- It's not been perfect.
OK, I get that.
So he deserves
some of the blame
but the real inconvenient truth
is the interior part
of their offensive line.
- Really?
- They got big-time issues
there, and that's really
the biggest reason you've seen
all three of their losses.
Sheldon Rankins whupped them
for the Saints, OK?
Eddie Goldman and Akiem Hicks
whupped them when the
Bears beat them, right?
- Dominated.
- Fletcher Cox and your Eagles
whupped their butt
this past week.
- I don't know how that happened.
- That's the inconvenient truth.
Now they can't win any of those
battles on the inside.
Their running game's
not working, and, of course
pressure is getting
into Goff's face
and he's not as sharp, either.
- I have one more inconvenient truth
- One more—
- And it's me to you.
- Oh, gosh.
It's inconvenient that I gotta
work with you on a daily basis.
- All right, well, now I'm not
afraid to say it anymore.
I can't believe I'm saying this.
- What?
- He's over my shoulder.
I don't think Aaron Rodgers
is the best quarterback
in the NFL anymore.
- You sound like my son Phillip,
who last week
was watching Patrick Mahomes
on Thursday night and said
"Mahomes is better than
Aaron Rodgers now, Dad."
- Look, I'm just happy
that one Simms in the family
has some sense,
but I think that Patrick Mahomes
is far and away better
than Aaron Rodgers.
- Get out of the studio.
Get out of the studio.
- We have a shrine.
- This is blasphemy!
- I think he is.
- He's the second shrine in here.
Blasphemy. Get out.
I don't even know who you are.
- I think that that should
become the primary shrine.
- Where is Adam Lefkoe? Who—
what—where did my host go?
- I'm just saying that—
- He doesn't have Tyreek Hill
he didn't have Kareem Hunt,
he doesn't have Andy Reid
he doesn't have Sammy Watkins,
he doesn't have Travis Kelce.
♪ Aaron Rodgers,
you're still the greatest ♪
♪ But even the greatest
needs help sometimes ♪
- I just— I'm not saying
he's worse than two.
- Yeah.
- I'm just sayin' he's not one.
- It's the first year—
I'm not gonna lie
I've had moments where I've—
- Say it. Say it.
- Nope. I've had moments
where I've gone
"Huh, this is getting
kinda close."
- You said, "Huh."
- I said, "Huh.
This is getting kinda close."
- Wow.
- But I'm still not gonna
give him the nod yet.
- The best part
that it was Phillip
is I can keep "Simms & Lefkoe"
and just replace you with him.
- Oh, thanks.
- I love that.
- Thanks a lot.
- Me and an eight-year-old
comin' next week.